celle ci doit j'espère que vous allez
bien on continue de passer en revue le
programme de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle aujourd'hui je
vous présente le programme de nicolas
dupont aignan le candidat du parti
debout la france alors l'idée c'est de
vous donner un bon aperçu en évoquant
dix mesures majeures évidemment on peut
pas tout les évoquer car son programme
on compte près de 100 je précise aussi
que ce décryptage visa en complément de
son interview dans l'interview face
cachée une interview qui sort dans
quelques jours sur cette même chaîne
youtube du coup n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si jamais ce n'est pas encore le
cas pour découvrir cette interview et
les suivantes
allez on commence comme d'habitude avec
une petite présentation nicolas dupont
aignan à 60 ans il est notamment diplômé
de sciences po paris puis de l'ena en
1989 en politique nicolas dupont aignan
a été élu à plusieurs reprises notamment
député de l'essonne depuis
1997 il a aussi été élu maire de yerres
dans l'essonne de 1995 à 2007 nicolas
dupont aignan a d'abord appartenu au
parti de droite l'ump qui s'appelle
désormais les républicains mais il a
ensuite créé en 2008 son propre parti le
parti debout la france sa troisième
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
après 2012 et 2017 il avait obtenu 1
69% des voix au premier tour en 2012 et
puis 4 7% des voix cinq ans plus tard en
2007 est d'ailleurs en 2017 nicolas
dupont aignan a soutenu marine le pen au
second tour en échangeant fait du poste
de premier ministre si elle l'emportait
ça ne s'est pas produit vous l'aurez
remarqué puisque c'est bien et mener le
maquereau qui a été élu au final
président et pour 2022 marine le pen a
proposé en fait une nouvelle alliance à
nicolas dupont aignan cette fois ci donc
dès le premier tour mais lui a refusé
préférant donc se présenter seul avec
son programme à lui alors là toutes
premières mesures que prendra nicolas
dupont aignan s'il est élu c'est de
supprimer toutes les restrictions
sanitaires et notamment de mettre fin
aux passes vaccinale auquel ils étaient
opposés depuis le début en fait ils
considèrent que c'est une privation de
liberté alors d'ici le premier tour en
avril peut-être que ça n'existera déjà
plus en france mais c'est tout de même
important d'en parler aujourd'hui
puisque depuis le d vu de la pandémie il
s'oppose en fait aux restrictions
sanitaires du gouvernement deuxième
mesure souhaitée par nicolas dupont
aignan c'est une augmentation de 8 % du
salaire de tous les français qui gagnent
moins de 3 fois le smic c'est à dire
donc qui gagnent moins de 4800 euros
brut par mois environ concrètement cette
augmentation de salaire ça reviendrait
au versement d'un 13e mois donc un mois
supplémentaire de salaires pour rendre
cela possible il veut en fait réduire
les cotisations salariales qui sont donc
ces impôts prélevés par l'état sur le
salaire avant qu'il n'arrive sur le
compte en banque de l'employé cette
réduction des cotisations salariales
selon lui coûterait environ 20 milliards
d'euros à l'état par an mais ce serait
financé selon lui toujours par les
économies tirées de la lutte contre la
fraude à la carte vitale car selon lui
il ya 1,8 millions de fausses cartes
vitale en circulation en france mais
c'est un chiffre en l'occurrence très
contesté on a eu l'occasion d'en parler
dans le cadre de son interview autres
mesures économiques nicolas dupont
aignan souhaite rétablir lisf un impôt
en fait sur les très grandes fortunes
qui avait été supprimée par emmanuel
macron avec quelques modifications mais
dont je vous passe les détails
aujourd'hui troisième mesure proposée
par nicolas dupont aignan c'est la
suppression de la loi qui aménage les
peines de prison courte cette loi avait
été votée en 2019 pour mettre en place
des peines alternatives à la prison
lorsqu'il s'agit de délits au-delà de ça
nicolas dupont aignan veut être plus
ferme et il souhaite aussi abaisser la
majorité pénale à 16 ans ce qui ferait
en gros que quelqu'un ayant 16 ans
serait jugé comme quelqu'un et un majeur
et il veut créer 40000 places de prison
supplémentaires en france en utilisant
donc une partie des casernes qui sont
aujourd'hui désaffectée on continue avec
la quatrième mesure qui concerne aussi
la justice le candidat souhaite expulser
les délinquants étrangers à l'issue de
leur peine il propose même que leur
emprisonnement se fasse dans leur pays
d'origine quand cela est possible
il veut également renvoyé les mineurs
isolés étrangers c'est-à-dire donc ces
jeunes de moins de 18 ans arrivé en
france sans représentant légal en france
faut savoir que actuellement dans le
pays les mineurs isolés étrangers
bénéficient de ce que l'on appelle la
protection de l'enfance qui leur donne
un sens nombre de droits à noter au
passage que comme marine le pen ou
encore eric zemmour nicolas dupont
aignan veut supprimer le droit du sol le
droit du sol c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui un enfant né en france de
parents étrangers obtient la nationalité
française à sa majorité
sous certaines conditions cinquième
mesure nicolas dupont aignan souhaite
sortir de l'union européenne ont en tout
cas il veut sortir de l'union européenne
telle qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui
pour lui en fait cette organisation est
inefficace dangereuse et dépasser joue
en fait la remplacer par une communauté
des nations libres en gros ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est plus favorisés en fait
des réunions en petits groupes avec
trois ou quatre pays autour de projets
spécifiques et s'il est élu il arrêtera
donc immédiatement toutes les
négociations pour l'élargissement de
l'union européenne et l'intégration dont
deux nouveaux pays puisqu'il souhaite
avant tout et bien changé l'union
européenne et changer ce fonctionnement
de coopération entre les pays européens
6e mesure pour redonner un pouvoir de
décision aux français ils souhaitent
faire adopter ses grandes réformes par
référendum donc en faisant voter la
population et dans ce même but il veut
aussi instaurer leur hic le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ce qui est
défendue notamment par les gilet jaune
en gros dés qu'un projet est soutenu par
cinq cent mille citoyens inscrits sur
les listes électorales et qui votent ou
qui signe par exemple sur une sorte de
pétition mise en place par l'état en
ligne et bien cette loi ou cette
proposition est ensuite soumise au
référendum c'est une mesure qui est
porté notamment par d'autres candidats
tels que françois asselineau ou encore
jean luc mélenchon nicolas dupont aignan
souhaite également revenir à un mandat
pour le président de la république qui
durait sept ans contre cinq ans
aujourd'hui et qui serait par contre non
renouvelable ce qui veut dire que et
bien un président ne peut pas être élu
deux fois d'affilée par exemple et au
delà de ça et bien il souhaite mettre en
place un référendum à mi-mandat qui
permettrait de destituer le président
donc au bout de trois ans et demi dans
le cas d'un mandat de sept ans la
population sera en mesure de voter pour
maintenir ou non le président au pouvoir
c'est ce que propose notamment un
françois asselineau sur ce référendum de
mi-mandat et enfin il souhaite que le
vote blanc soit prise en compte lors des
élections et que le résultat d'une
élection soit annulée si le vote blanc
est majoritaire 7e mesure qui semble
importante a évoqué nicolas dupont
aignan veut créer un service national
civique obligatoire de trois mois pour
les femmes comme les hommes pour faire
simple à leurs 18 ans tous les jeunes
devront participer à des missions de
service public pendant trois mois ils
pourront aussi passer leur permis de
conduire gratuitement en échange de ses
missions ses trois mois obligatoire
pourrait être prolongée par un service
militaire d'un an qui serait facultatif
dont l'objectif serait d'augmenter le
nombre de soldats réservistes donc le
nombre de soldats militaire à temps
partiel qui ont en fait un autre métier
mais qui peuvent être appelés en cas de
conflit ou alors de crise majeure enfin
sur la défense s'il est élu nicolas
dupont aignan veut recruter 40 mille
soldats de plus pendant son mandat 8e
mesure nicolas dupont aignan propose de
créer un contrat de travail pour les
jeunes et les chômeurs de longue durée
en fait ce serait une somme d'argent
versée en échange d'une activité
d'intérêt général a mis ton qui serait
destinée donc aux jeunes et aux
personnes au chômage depuis longtemps ça
reprend un petit peu le principe du
contrat d'engagement des bagnes et le
maquereau et du revenu jeune actif qui
est proposée par vale pécresse mais là
deux différences majeures pour déjà
amené le maquereau et valérie pécresse
conditionne à cette allocation donc
cette somme d'argent à une formation par
un travail d'intérêt général et ensuite
cette allocation de nicolas dupont
aignan s'adresse aussi aux chômeurs de
longue durée et donc pas seulement aux
jeunes nicolas dupont aignan est par
ailleurs opposé au fait de verser une
somme d'argent à tous les jeunes sans
condition comme peuvent le proposer un
certain nombre de candidats à gauche
anne hidalgo par exemple qui propose de
verser 5000 euros à tous les jeunes à
leurs 18 ans 9e mesure désormais porté
par le candidat de debout la france elle
concerne l'éducation et bien nicolas
dupont aignan veut rétablir le bac comme
il était avant la réforme du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer ça veut dire notamment remettre
en place les filières l es ou es ce que
vous avez peut-être connu mais aussi à
supprimer la prise en compte du contrôle
continu dans l'obtention du bac nicolas
dupont aignan souhaite également
augmenter et passer de 9 heures à 15
heures le temps habdomadaire qui est
consacré aux français et aux maths à
l'école primaire et enfin il souhaite
aussi augmenter le salaire brut des
enseignants de 20% 10e mesure nicolas
dupont aignan veut mettre fin aux
déserts médicaux ce sont donc ces zones
où la population rencontrent des
difficultés pour accéder à des soins de
santé car il n'y a plus de médecins dans
les environs et ou alors les hôpitaux
sont loin il propose donc de rouvrir un
hôpital ou une maternité dans chaque
département il souhaite aussi doubler le
nombre de médecins d'infirmières
scolaires ou encore d'assistante sociale
dans tout le pays augmenté de 15% leur
salaire brut et accorder des primes
spéciales aux gens qui travaillent dans
les hôpitaux et enfin il veut également
créer 80 mille postes supplémentaires
dont les étals et ouvrir 250 mille
places de crèches supplémentaires on
termine avec quelques autres mesures
rapidement ils souhaitent maintenir le
nucléaire à 70% dans la production
d'énergie comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour produire l'électricité en france il
veut aussi supprimer toutes les
éoliennes qui selon lui pourrissent les
paysages nicolas dupont aignan est aussi
contre la légalisation du cannabis il ne
souhaite pas non plus interdire ou
limiter la chasse autre mesure nicolas
dupont aignan souhaite développer
fortement les transports en commun
propres hybrides ou encore électrique il
souhaite lancer un remplacement des 5
millions de véhicules les plus polluants
d'ici 10 ans et enfin dans le domaine de
la culture on pourrait noter qu'il
souhaite notamment ouvrir les musées
gratuitement le dimanche aux français
rêve pour compléter donc cette vidéo je
vous invite à regarder également son
interview qui va être disponible dans
quelques jours sur cette même chaîne
youtube comme les interviews d'ailleurs
des autres candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
les programmes aussi des autres
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
n'hésitez pas du coup à vous abonner
directement à cette chaîne youtube pour
ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes comme
d'habitude je vous mets des petits les
en descriptions je tiens aussi à vous
dire que pour découvrir des comparatifs
des programmes des candidats à la
présidentielle ça se passera dans les
prochains jours directement sur notre
compte instagram une bonne équipe
écoutez je crois que j'ai tout dis
prenez soin de vous produire nos proches
et on se dit ah très vite